il y a huit ans jean charest faisait
l'histoire un gouvernement paritaire
une première à québec avec des femmes à
des postes clés comme monique jérôme
forget est au conseil du trésor et aux
finances elle se réjouit de voir justin
trudeau
suivant l'exemple c'est clair que nous
avons des préoccupations différentes
qu'on a des responsabilités différents
convois le monde différemment les
gouvernements paritaires sont encore
suffisamment rare à travers le monde
pour que l'événement soit chaque fois
souligné
c'était le cas en espagne en 2004 où le
président zapatero a marqué le coup avec
huit femmes ministres sur 16
c'est le cas en france depuis trois ans
l'engagement du président hollande de
respecter la parité au conseil des
ministres est scrupuleusement suivi
reste ensuite à voir s'il s'agit
uniquement d'une parité quantitative à
savoir on a fait moitié-moitié ou s'il
ya aussi une parité qualitative à savoir
est ce que les femmes ont des
portefeuilles importants
il s'avère qu'en france tout ne va pas
si rondes main malgré la parité des lois
mises de l'avant par des ministres
femmes ont été affaiblis ou carrément
rejeté par l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
ont une chose en commun c'est qu'elles
sont composés à environ 75 % d'hommes
qui font et défont les lois du pays
donc il s'agit pas seulement d'avoir un
gouvernement paritaire il faut aussi qu
à toutes les strates du pouvoir n'est
une parité si on veut vraiment que ça
bouge la france un des derniers pays
occidentaux à avoir accordé le droit de
vote aux femmes avance sur la voie de la
parité à pas de géant
il y a quelques mois laissant une
assemblée régionale que compte le pays
sont devenus paritaire du jour au
lendemain grâce à une réforme électorale
qui oblige les candidats à se présenter
en temps des hommes femmes s'il y a un
conseil c'est d'être absolument
intransigeant sur le sexisme qui risque
de s'abattre sur ces femmes c'est
quelque chose qu'on a vu en france nous
un autre danger guette la parité elle
peut être de courte durée
au québec la parité n'a pas survécu au
gouvernement charest
madame marois une femme pourtant n'a pas
jugé bon de continuer l'expérience
libérale en absence d'une règle
contraignante
tout repose donc sur les convictions et
la détermination du premier ministre ici
alexandre achat de ce cap radio canada
montréal